gamer's what's up it's time for me
beauty pie to play some more video games
look at this
Jesus Christ I'm fast so this game is
called Pablo it's supposed to be like
it's supposed to be like counter-strike
but for for VR did I grab that oh my god
can I pick it up for ya I definitely
have the controls figure it out okay
here we frickin go time to kill some
noobs oh my god how am I so fast it will
[ __ ] wait how do i buy some on the vibe
I think it's right on the [ __ ] someone
buy me a gun please please please Arvid
plates yeah geez I guess we're going
knifes I'll Arvin oh how cool I have
done that thanks Arvin okay okay where I
got this just take it easy I'm actually
scared okay oh gosh my teammates took
okay oh this is the same map as
counter-strike okay okay
you're gonna mess with me boy that's my
teammate isn't it yeah okay cool hey hey
hey I need help
Bravo thank you there's a great clear
we're clear all right unless they're
coming around I'll make sure I'll cover
your back you're kind of camping dude I
mean okay
oh I'm double K I'm camping for you yeah
hey look at that look at that it works
thanks to me oh god damn Oh what do you
do
put down the night put down the knife
put it down man okay okay good
cool I'm John all right finally have a
gun
oh all right well I'm gonna go this way
yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] how do I relive
[ __ ] drop it drop it
that's how we do it in Sweden okay this
is actually scary the place where they
shoot Hey look at that did everything
you're welcome guys you're welcome
trying to do a knife here team this time
hey did everyone has anyone ever told
you you sound like jacksepticeye oh
really Wow no I headed never because
they sound like markiplier let me ahead
stab the spot stop telling the bots the
tactic what you're not even jerking
enough dude you got to do it over here
this is like he's like right here stop
jacking people up I got him
oh yeah that's how it's done I got him
you didn't boy I killed literally oh oh
oh really
sure you sound a while I paid for septic
to skeptical because I've been on your
wall I really appreciate your content
you've gotten me through some tough
times okay come back here Wow what the
Frank can I get a gun please
yeah here you go oh thanks I got you
okay
let's do this we got guns Oh
[Music]
you got it pump it Oh
load it yeah Josie I gotta thank you
yeah there you go thank you so much
okay for real how do I open the menu for
for guns and [ __ ] um out of either rift
vibe it's right on the right for me oh
yeah I got it thank you
let's hold this point again yeah it
worked out really well oh yeah shaken I
don't know why
let's go let's go shot me things oh I
see okay now I should be able to buy now
I have no money [ __ ] is a double-barrel
any good yes because you can stop them
movie I don't know the Clockwork Orange
oh we have the same one is that what you
asked
oh no I actually didn't what the hell is
this why was I so will you show me send
one home then I went home
hello hey hey dad don't forget shoot me
again I'll kill you
oh really well I have a ham America
wait cover me one second I lost my
headphone don't worry I drop the grenade
did call me I ain't supposed to be in
the garage
oh hey Becky I'm a tickle you didn't
just kill oh yeah oh yeah that's right
anyone else want some
haha hey yo yeah yep nope nope nope nope
god damn it you're dead now you came to
the wrong hood you can't Oh what are you
gonna do now
hey what the Frick all right say you're
sorry say you're sorry say you're how
damn it stop running oh you try it again
alright that's it that's it for me
playing Pablo
oh boy that sure was fun hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did smash like
subscribe so we can be t-series and
that's all Bros for now what and that's
all for now browse
[Music]
[Applause]